All Objective C objects inherit an init
method from the NS object class.
So unlike in Swift,
it's not always necessary to
implement a custom initializer.
If I go into the main function
of our house project,
I can initialize an instance of
the house class with no problem.
You've seen this a few times now.
Every time you create an object,
you type alloc, which allocates
some memory space and then init to
initialize the object instance.
Alloc and
init are always written together.
They're like entangled particles.
They can't be separated.
That being said,
this house I initialized has no address.
So I think we should write
a custom initializer.
We'll write our custom
initializer in the House.m file.
This is the first method
we're writing together.
So let's take a minute to talk about
the syntax of method definitions.
Every method definition
starts with the return type.
In this case, our return type
is going to be instancetype.
Instancetype indicates an instance of
the class in which this method is found,
in this case,
an instance of the House class.
After the return type,
we'll type init, no surprise there.
But generally,
you're going to want to initialize
an instance of a class with some values.
So it's common to name your
initializer initWithSomeProperty.
In our case, we'll initWithAddress, and
then we place a colon
after the method name.
After the colon, we pass in our
parameter, address, and of course,
address is going to be
a pointer to a string.
We indicate the parameter type
here in between parentheses and
include an asterisk to show that
the parameter is a pointer to an object.
After the parameter type comes
the parameter itself, address, and
then some curly braces to
hold the body of the method.
So the general form for writing
a method definition looks like this,
the returnType between parentheses,
the methodName followed by a colon,
the parameterType between parentheses.
If the parameter is an object,
include an asterisk, the parameterName,
and then in between curly braces,
the body of the method.
Now let's get back to initialization.
Every init method is going to start
out by calling the init method of its
superclass, which in this case,
is NSObject.
So we set self = [super init].
Next we want to check that everything
went well with that call to super init.
So we type if(self).
Self should have a value now, so
this statement should evaluate to true.
Then in the body of this if statement,
we'll initialize our properties.
I place an underscore
here before address, and
this is how I access the address
instance variable directly.
Remember that address is marked
with the attribute copy, so
we want to initialize it with a copy
of the string that's being passed in.
This line protects the address
from the unintentional changes
we talked about earlier.
So again,
we set _address equal to a copy of
address, the parameter being passed in.
We'll give these other
properties default values.
Let's say the default
numberOfBedrooms is 2 and
the default value of hasHotTub is false.
When we're done setting the values
of the properties, we return self.